hallo leute manchmal höre ich bei
deutsch lernen sätze wie ich wohne jetzt
in bochum oder meine familie ist noch in
syrien korrekt heißt es ich wohne jetzt
in bochum und meine familie ist noch in
syrien
aber was ist der unterschied zwischen
inn und im das gucken wir uns heute an
in ist die original form der präposition
in ist also die präposition im auf der
anderen seite ist eine zusammengesetzte
form aus der präposition in und dem man
benutzt im also nur dann wenn man die
präposition in mit einem wort kombiniert
das einen artikel hat und dieser artikel
muss männlich sein und im dativ stehen
dem ich bin in dem geschäft ich bin im
geschäft
woher weiß man ob ein wort einen artikel
hat oder nicht
normalerweise haben alle worte im
deutschen artikel ausnahmen städte und
länder ich sage zum beispiel immer bei
stetten
ich bin in berlin ich bin in hamburg und
bei ländern sagt man fast immer in zum
beispiel ich bin in deutschland ich bin
in mexiko denn fast alle länder haben
keine artikel
es gibt aber ein paar ausnahmen wie zum
beispiel der irak oder der jemen oder
die usa welche das sind darüber haben
wir schon mal ein video gemacht und das
könnt ihr jetzt hier oben sehen wenn ihr
wollt
alle anderen namen benutzt man mit einem
artikel
und jetzt muss man noch wissen ob der
artikel männlich neutral oder weiblich
ist man sagt zum beispiel die schule
ich bin in der
oder das haus ich bin in dem also im
haus woher weiß ich ob ein wort ein
nomen einen weiblichen neutralen oder
männlichen artikel hat ich muss es
einfach auswendig lernen es ist wichtig
dass ihr diese artikel immer direkt
zusammen mit den vokabeln lernt was auch
wichtig ist ihnen wird immer mit einem
dativ benutzt wenn ihr einen ort
beschreibt an dem ihr gerade seid oder
an dem jemand gerade ist wenn ihr einen
ort beschreibt zudem ihr gerade geht
oder von dem ihr weg geht dann benutzt
ihr den akkusativ mit in zum beispiel
ich sage ich bin in der schule dativ und
ich gehe in die schule akkusativ das ist
eine so genannte wechsel präposition und
im englischen nennt man das auch tooway
positions in ist so eine wechsel
präposition darüber haben wir schon mal
ein ganzes video gemacht und das findet
ihr jetzt hier jetzt zeigen wir euch
beispiele in denen wir in mit dem dativ
benutzen also es geht immer darum einen
ort zu beschreiben an dem wir gerade
sind ohne uns zu bewegen dann könnt ihr
hören wenn wir in und wann wir im
benutzen wir fangen an mit dem
weiblichen artikel die mülltonne
das glas liegt in der mülltonne
die eberswalder straße ich bin in der
eberswalder straße die toilette
ich bin in der toilette die konferenz
ich bin in der konferenz
es geht weiter mit männlichen worden
der biergarten ich bin im biergarten der
biergarten ist aber im winter
geschlossen
der hof ich bin in dem hof ich bin im
hof der bauwagen
ich bin in dem bauwagen ich bin im
bauwagen das haus ich bin in dem haus
ich bin im haus der briefkasten
wir haben keine post im briefkasten nur
werbung ja ja das denke ich auch das
gespräch ich bin in dem gespräch ich bin
im gespräch mit meiner schwester
okay sie machen wir das auto ich sitze
in dem auto ich sitze im auto das
gesicht
ich habe eine nase in dem gesicht
ich habe eine nase im gesicht das war
unser video zum thema in
das ist im wir hoffen ihr habt jetzt den
unterschied verstanden und
herausgefunden wann man eben und wann
man in benutzt jetzt könnt ihr das ganze
noch sehr intensiv üben und zwar als
mitglied weil petzsche dann bekommt die
anleihen übungen zum thema und könnt
gucken ob er alles verstanden habt
außerdem solltet ihr uns bei facebook
und bei instagram folgen wie links
findet ihr unten in der infobox
tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche